allez on est reparti
bon bah écoutez moi je vais y aller nier
5h05 vos collègues prendront en cours de
route c'est bon alors je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait donc un
élément de débat qu'on pouvait avoir sur
le prix du kilowattheure dans les autres
éléments de débat il ya bien évidemment
la question des déchets alors en fait à
déchets vous savez que le dictionnaire
en donne une définition assez simple un
déchet c'est quelque chose dont on ne
sait plus quoi faire
c'est ça un déchet on va en voir
exactement le même genre de définition
en ce qui concerne le combustible
nucléaire
ceux qui rentrent dans une centrale
électrogènes c'est donc de l'uranium
enrichi ou comme je vous le dit tout à
l'heure il ya quelques courses en fait
je voulais pas dit mais il ya quelques
pourcents d'uranium 235 dans le total on
est donc passé de 0 7% dans l'uranium
naturel à trois et demi 4 % dans
l'uranium qu'on appelle enrichi est au
bout de quelques années on en sort 475
kg de nos 500 kg d'uranium qui sont
toujours d'uranium sauf que ça contient
très peu d'uranium 235 qui
essentiellement à 6 youn et on a cinq
kilos de plutonium et ce plutonium selon
la définition qu'on lui donne c'est un
déchet ou c'est pas un déchet et puis on
a à peu près d'un kilo de produits de
fission alors en fait quand je vous dis
on a à peu près 20 kg comme on a libéré
d'énergie nucléaire dans cette affaire
il va ressortir du réacteur un peu moins
que 500 kilos de combustible le reste
est e égal et ses 2 c'est à dire c'est
ce qui a permis de fournir l'énergie de
fission ce le défaut de masse des noix
et de ce qu'on a mis dans le réacteur de
conduire au sort 475 kg d'uranium 238
cet uranium 238
on peut éventuellement le mettre de côté
pour s'en servir dans des réacteurs qui
vont exploiter le cycle du plutonium
on ressort 5 kg de plutonium qui est
directement fissiles et on ressort 20 kg
de produits de fission donc c'est ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure du 16e du
strontium de liège etc qui sont des
cochonneries franchement radioactives et
danton là pour le coup on ne peut
absolument rien faire
ce qui va ressortir de réacteur à cause
de la radioactivité très forte de ses
produits de fission continue à dégager
des chaleurs donc en général la première
chose qu'on fait quand on enlève un
assemblage d'un coeur de réacteur ces
deux médecins dans une piscine ou
d'abord lui va protéger de la
radioactivité résiduelle et ensuite vous
allez grâce à l'eau de la piscine
pouvoir évacuer la chaleur de votre
assemblage un assemblage peu encore
rayonner quelques enfin peut encore
qu'est ce que je veux dire oui c'est ça
rayonnait quelques petits degrés de
puissance thermique les déchets ça
représente quoi
chacun d'entre vous directement ou
indirectement
vous êtes à l'origine d'à peu près 2 5
tonnes de déchets dans l'année
ces 2,5 tonnes c'est la petite demi
tonne d'ordures ménagères que vous
émettez fera que vous que vous engendrez
en direct et tout le reste c'est les 2
tonnes que l'industrie fabriquant des
produits pour votre compte va mettre
dans sa poubelle pour fabriquer
l'ordinateur dont je suis en train de me
servir
il faut faire des déchets il ya des
moments où on va faire des trucs dont on
sait pas quoi faire
ça peut être n'importe quoi entre des
résidus miniers des scories ci et là des
voix là des trucs qui sont pas
spécialement dangereux ou deux plus
grosses cochonneries qui avale entre
étaient alors les cochonneries vous et
moi on est en gros à l'origine
100 kg par an les cochonneries en
question ça peut être des solvants
usagés
ça peut être des produits qui
contiennent des métaux lourds ça peut
être etc
voilà c'est ça peut être des
phytosanitaires non utilisés là il
s'agit bien encore une fois de la
production française de cochonneries
rapporté au nombre de français c'est pas
nécessairement des choses que vous allez
jeter vous en direct basse et 100 kg par
personne et par an les résidus de
l'industrie électronucléaire représente
à peu près un kilo par français et par
an
là dedans vous avez 900 grammes qui ne
pose pas de problème particulier
vous allez voir ce qu'on en fait et vous
avez 100 grammes qui sont deux produits
qui vont durer longtemps au sein
desquels vous avez dit g c'est-à-dire
hors eu une ou deux pièces de monnaie
par personne et par an qui va être à la
fois des franges cochonneries et durer
un certain temps
achat sa veux dire toute activité donc
certes les déchets nucléaires sont des
produits qui sont assez désagréable si
vous vous retrouvez à leur contact
maintenant il faut bien voir que la
quantité qui est produite dans l'année
fait que pour le moment il ne pose pas
de problème majeur tout simplement parce
qu'il n'occupe pas beaucoup d'espoir à
ce que c'est des choses qui sont faciles
à confiner et facile à surveiller
si je regarde de quoi s'occuper de ses
déchets en question vous avez des uns
des déchets de très faible activité
alors des déchets de très faible
activité ça peut être je sais pas moi
quelque chose qui est un peu irradiés
dans le cadre du cycle nucléaire enfin
du du combustible
voilà un peu plus radioactifs que ce
qu'on avait au départ mais ça pose pas
de problème particulier
après vous avez des déchets qui sont
catalogués avec les sigles que vous
voyez là c'est à dire faible et moyenne
activité faible activité moyenne
activité et e activité alors la fête
ce qui pose vraiment un problème comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure enfin
ce qui est ce qui est vraiment délicat à
manipuler
c'est ce qu'on appelle les déchets de
haute activité donc rsa crash de l'alpha
et du béton et du gamin en veux tu en
voilà
et ça représente pour 40 ans pour 40 ans
de gestion du parc électrogène français
quelques milliers de mètres cubes à
quelques milliers de mètres cubes
il suffit d'avoir un entrepôt un peu
particulier et vous arrivez à les mettre
dedans alors ici vous avez l'entrepôt un
peu particulier qui gère des déchets de
faible activité dont vous voyez ces
hangars ou directement des espèces de
bâtiments dans lesquels vous mettez les
déchets puis après vous construisez le
toit par dessus et puis vous les laisser
là et puis à ma foi au moment ça occupe
un peu d espace ça va occuper un peu
d'espacé pendant un certain temps et ça
ne pose pas plus de problèmes que ça
l'une des caractéristiques des déchets
radioactifs et c'est une énorme
différence avec les déchets chimiques
c'est que même si c'est des franges
cochonneries et même si certains d'entre
eux vont rester des franges cochonneries
pendant une durée relativement longue
ils ont quand même une particularité ce
que leur radioactivité même fait que
leur toxicité évolué au cours du temps
la radiotoxicité évolué au cours du
temps
la radioactivité ça veut dire que les
noyaux se transforme et une fois qu une
désintégration a eu lieu le noyau
initial peut se transformer en un noyau
qui va prendre sa place qui est ou pas
radioactif du tout quand on est en fin
de chaîne de décroissance radioactive ou
quelque chose qui va l'être - et d'une
manière générale la toxicité des déchets
radioactifs est quelque chose qui dit
avec le temps donc encore une fois ça
peut durer longtemps pour qu'il devienne
moins radioactifs mais ça finit toujours
par arriver
vous savez ici un graphique qui vous
représente quelque chose de très
intéressant qui est la mise en place
pectives de la radioactivité de
l'uranium utilisé pour le combustible
initial et qui est à un niveau de
radioactivité qui ne pose pas de
problème particulier et le niveau de
radioactivité en examen selon une
échelle de great mis qu'un de ce que
vous récupérez quand vous avez sorti
votre assemblage du coeur du réacteur
alors vous voyez que ceux qui à la plus
forte activité au moment où vous sortez
l'assemblage du coeur du réacteur
c'est le produit de fission les produits
de fission
au bout de quelques siècles 500 600 700
ans sont revenus le matérieux que vous
avez extrait du coeur du réacteur a émis
à peu près tout ce qu'il avait à émettre
et il est revenu à un niveau de
dangerosité radioactives qui est à peu
près celle de l'uranium initial vous
allez dire certes quelques siècles c'est
quand même assez long effectivement
c'est assez long cela étant ce n'est pas
l'éternité c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
aussi dangereux en permanence après vous
avez un autre déchet ou pas à déchets ça
dépend ce qu'on choisit d'en faire qui
s'appelle le plutonium et si vous leur
mettez dans une autre centrale
c'est-à-dire soit dans une centrale qui
brûlent du mox soit les insurgés
narrateur fait ce truc là ça cesse
d'être un déchet donc certes c'est
radioactifs mais enfin si vous le mettez
dans une centrale ça va disparaître
puisque ça va fonctionner et vous aurez
pu vous en occuper si vous en occuper
comme un déchet alors effectivement il
faut attendre de l'aide de la centaine
de milliers d'années avant que le
plutonium en question soit revenu
fonctionnement ses descendants soit
revenu par unité de masse à un niveau de
radioactivité qui est comparable à celui
de l'uranium initial et puis ici vous
avez ce qu'on appelle les actinides
mineurs donc c'est les autres actinides
que le plutonium
donc ce qui a un numéro atomique
supérieur à 89 en pratique supérieur à
92 en général aient enfin ici nous aller
ce qu'on appelle les produits
d'activation à la le produit
d'activation c'est tout ce qui entourait
le
un rédacteur ou plus exactement tout ce
qui entourait le combustible
ça peut concerner en particulier les
gaines qui contiennent les pastilles
d'oxydé d'uranium dans l'assemblage et
qui a reçu des neutrons et qui donc
c'est transmuter est devenu d'autres
choses de radio actifs afin d' autre
chose que la matière et que le matériau
initial et cet autre chose et
radioactifs soit dit en passant parce
que je vous en reparlerai tout à l'heure
les produits d'activation vous les avez
dès que vous avez une réaction nucléaire
qui vous crachent des neutrons donc ces
produits d'activation vous en
retrouverez également dans la fusion si
un jour l'homme sait contrôler la fusion
à partir de parce que la fusion ça va
aussi craché des nôtres ont donc vous
allez avoir également ce qu'on appelle
des produits d'activation c'est à dire
le résultat du bombardement du matériau
qui entoure le coeur du réacteur par le
flux de neutrons qui est issu de la
réaction nucléaire
donc ces produits d'activation c'est
tellement des déchets qu'il faut gérer
cela étant vous voyez que ces produits
d'activation bon au bout de un siècle et
demi en gros ils sont pas plus dangereux
que l'uranium initial et encore une fois
ce niveau de dangerosité là ne
présentent pas d'inconvénient
particulier donc les deux chez yamaha y
en a certains qu'il faut conserver
pendant des durées relativement longue
mais en fait celui qu'il faut conserver
pendant la durée les plus longues on
peut c'est une question de choix
technologiques faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas un déchet humain peut décider
que ça reste un déchet mais vous voyez
que l'on y encore une fois il ya une
question de choix subjectif dans la
définition d'un déchet je vous rappelle
qu'un déchet c'est quelque chose dont on
ne peut plus rien faire
le plutonium on peut en faire quelque
chose si on veut donc la question est de
savoir si on veut ou si on veut pas
parce qu'on trouve qu'il ya trop
d'inconvénients à faire mais c'est une
question de choix
c'est pas une question de la possibilité
technique dans les autres inconvénients
qui sont souvent évoqués en ce qui
concerne la génération des nerfs
puis à partir du nucléaire il ya bien
évidemment l'effet de la radioactivité
sur les êtres vivants alors le fait de
la radioactivité sur les êtres vivants
elle peut arriver de deux manières elle
peut arriver dans la conduite normal des
opérations vous avez des gens qui
travaillent dans des centrales
nucléaires ils reçoivent un petit
surplus de radioactivité vous avez des
gens qui travaillent dans les mines
d'uranium ils reçoivent un petit surplus
d'activité cetera il n'y a pas vraiment
moyen de faire autrement
donc ça c'est une première les
radiations liées à l'industrie
électronucléaire et puis vous avez une
deuxième forme d'irradiation c'est celle
qui est pas blanc terre c'est à dire
celle qui est liée soit à une dame qui
explosent pour la forme des radiations
que pas volontaire soit à une centrale
qui a un accident et c'est aussi une
forme des radiations qui n'est pas
spécialement volontaire alors la
première chose qu'il faut rappeler c'est
que tous les êtres vivants ne sont pas
égaux devant les radiations
vous avez peut-être lu des livres de
science fiction dans lequel après une
guerre nucléaire totale il restait sur
terre des rats et les cafards
c'est pas un hasard qu'on ait choisi des
rats et les cafards en particulier des
cafards
parce que les insectes sont
considérablement plus résistants que les
êtres vivants à l'effet des radiations
pour mesurer l'effet des radiations sur
les êtres vivants
les médecins et les biologistes sont
obligés d'utiliser des tas d'unités
compliqué dont je vais vous donner la
principale info exactement la première
de la liste qui s'appelle le grès le
grelle définition très simple un grès et
un jour une énergie transmise à un kilo
de matière par du rayonnement on vient
dire ajoute par kilo c'est vraiment pas
grand chose quant au chauffard lido dans
la casserole je lui dois votre alors
plus qu un joule oui certes sauf que
comme c'est du rayonnement et que c'est
ionisants et bien un grès est déjà
largement suffisant pour commencer à
faire des dommages dans un certain
nombre de tissus et toujours pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur
une irradiation corps entier de telles
que gré de quelques degrés pour
n'importe lequel d'entre vous a priori
ça vous tue c'est suffisant pour vous
tuer donc la quantité d'énergie qu'il
faut communiquer à 1 est révolue et
enfin je sais pas si ça vous prouver un
est révolue pour le tuer donc un
mammifère supérieure pour le tuer et de
la beauté
jules par kilo de poids avec des
rayonnements ionisants ça suffit pour
désorganiser suffisamment la machine
pour qu'il ait des ennuis très grave
derrière quand on est dans des deux
beaucoup plus faible heureusement on n'a
pas de résultats aussi immédiat et je
vous en parlerai un peu plus tard mais
là simplement donc vous avez ici la
plage de doses létales pour les êtres
vivants en fonction de la nature de
l'être vivant dont on parle et de la
deux en grève donc ici vous avez la deux
avec une échelle logarithmique donc là
vous êtes a dit gré là vous êtes à
ingres est là à 100 à 1000 à 10000 est
ici vous avez les différentes catégories
d'être vivant il ya un virus par exemple
il faut commencer à lui envoyer 200 300
jeunes par kg pour 1 sous forme de
rayonnement pour qu'ils en sont la trace
avant pourrait bien faire ce que vous
voulez il s'en fiche
si vous allez vers des êtres un peu plus
évolués comme par exemple les
protozoaires et bien vous descendez un
peu plus bas dans le rayonnement qui
commencent à leur faire des misères et
serra et caetera et veuves au lieu que
les mammifères et en particulier les
mammifères supérieurs comme nous nous
sommes le plus sensibles aux
rayonnements ionisants
ce qui veut dire que quand vous avez un
accident de type tchernobyl
il n'est pas très étonnant il n'est pas
très étonnant que le problème concerne
essentiellement les hommes et que en ce
qui concerne la nature vous n'ayez pas
de conséquence observable de manière
significative et de fête
ça va peut-être choquer certains d'entre
vous exactement comme ça que les choses
se sont passées
l'accident de tchernobyl a été pour
l'essentiel de la vie sauvage une
bénédiction parce que comme on a évacué
tous les aime d'un rayon de 30 km autour
de la centrale
on a retiré le super prédateur qui
complique la vie tous les animaux de la
zone en question et comme par ailleurs
on est dans des dames de rayonnement
dans lesquelles le essentielle de la vie
n'est pas en continu par ce qui se passe
est bien en vie on a fait une réserve
naturelle fait la majeure partie de la
vie qui s'y trouvait mais parfaitement
contente de se trouver là tous les des
comptes qui ont été faits montrent que
tous les gros
mammifère par exemple se sont mis à
proliférer dont il ya plein de sangliers
de serre dedans et c'est que voilà donc
la hongrie et la vie animale ça peut
paraître étonnant mais je rappelle
qu'une réserve naturelle
ça n'est rien d'autre qu'un endroit où
on dit à l'homme de paille et ses patins
essentiellement ça et bien le bénéfice
lié à la disparition des êtres humains
pour la ville la vigne sauvage
évidemment et a été supérieur un
inconvénient deux du fond de
radioactivité un peu plus élevé que qui
a été créé dans l'argent jeu il ya une
autre raison à cela c'est que une bonne
partie des êtres vivants ont des durées
de vie qui sont significativement plus
courte que m
donc si vous avez des mécanismes
biologiques qui met 20 30 40 ans à
apparaître vous prenez n'importe quel
animal qui vit quinze ans c'est pas son
problème
je vais y venir après je vais venir
après la question a justement à qui il
faut faire confiance
et pourquoi quand on s'intéresse à ce
genre de sujet et là en l'occurrence
pour répondre à votre question par
avance la réponse est non mais je vous
dirai après kiki qui se positionne comme
ans sur ce genre de chien là j'en suis
juste a encore une fois un point qui est
qu' il ne fait pas penser encore une
fois que tous les êtres vivants sont
également sensibles aux rayonnements
andreu c'est comme quand un château de
cartes plus deux êtres sont complexes et
plus une même quantité une même quantité
d'énergie transmises par un rayonnement
ionisant déstabilise le système la
deuxième unité qui est utilisé par les
biologistes pour caractériser les effets
des rayonnements est un truc qui
s'appelle le psy verte alors le si verte
c'est comme le rapport du giec pour la
presse qu'en public
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il existe plus de
trois journalistes dans le pays qu'ils
sachent comment se définit ainsi verte à
mon avis trois est déjà beaucoup
même moi je connais pas les clés de
répartition de manière exacte
l'idée du si verte c'est de moduler le
rayonnement reçue
donc vous êtes vous avez une unité
physique j'allais dire qui est une unité
d'énergie par kilo classé le grès après
si vous voulez avoir une unité
biologique
c'est à dire quelque chose qui vous
permettent d'évaluer les dommages il va
falloir bu du lait ça avec deux
paramètres le premier essai qu'elle est
l'organisme où le tissu qui est irradié
parce que selon qu'on vous irradie la
thyroïde le biceps gauche à noces ou les
lycées adroit avec la même quantité de
joules par kilo vous n'avez pas les
mêmes résultats
et avec quels types de particules vous
irradiés parce que selon vous utilisez
bataille gamal fins et très peu
pénétrant sauf quand vous respirez
et bien vous n'avez pas non plus les
mêmes effets donc les biologistes ont
mis au point un truc qui s'appelle le si
verte et qui est une unité de conversion
du grès enfin à partir du grec qui ce
qui ce qui se calcule à partir du grès
et qui ne se calcule pas la même manière
selon vous avez affaire à des alfa des
bêta ou à du gamin est selon vous avez à
faire un tissu comme ceci ou un tissu
comme cela ok une grande grande greer
qui vous dit ben voilà un grès si c'est
une irradiation bêta à la thyroïde ça
autant de cils rt si c'est une
irradiation alpha dans les poumons c'est
en ti vertes et 6 etc
en pratique l'unité qui est utilisé la
plupart du temps c'est pas le sievert
c'est un de ses sous multiples qui est
le mini siewert et là aussi il faut
avoir quelque chose en tête qui est que
l'irradiation habituel pour un français
est de l'ordre de 2 5 millisieverts par
an alors c'est bien évidemment une
noyade
donc je prends ce que reçoivent tous les
français toute l'année et j'en fais une
moyenne par individu
mais c'est susceptible de varier d'une
région à une autre et d'une altitude à
une autre vous voyez par exemple que
dans ceux tirade iations naturel une
première partie de cette irradiation
naturel vient tout simplement de radios
des scanners et autres choses de ce type
que vous passez parce que quand on vous
en bien et passer une radio on peut soit
vous on vous injecte enfin je veux dire
on vous passe à des rayonnements
ionisants notamment les rayons x et ça
ça qu'est ce que je veux dire c'est une
partie et manac majeure partie de
l'irradiation que vous recevez chaque
année ensuite vous avez une partie
des rayonnements ionisants que vous la
sauvez qui est dû aux rayonnements
cosmiques et la plus vous allez souvent
au ski plus vous ne recevez plus vous
prenez souvent l'avion plus à sauver
ici vous avez l'exposition au radon
le radon est un gaz radioactif qui elle
donnait vie très très bref je m'en
rappelle plus mais c'est très très bref
qui est un descendant du radium et donc
on va en trouver à proximité des sols
granitiques
quand vous avez une cave mal aéré de
maisons dans une région granitique la
bretagne au massif central
vous avez les petites concentrations de
radon qui s'accumulent sera don est un
gars voulaient respirer les descendants
du radon sont par contre solide
il vient de se fixer sur les poumons et
là il vous bombarde avec les alfa et
s'il vous bombarde suffisamment ne
finissez par attraper un cancer du
poumon
on prête au radon entre 1000 et 2000
morts en france par an mais vous allez
voir un peu plus tard que c'est
extrêmement difficile en fait d'avoir
des ordres de grandeur qui se tiennent
là dedans une partie de la radioactivité
vous la mangez elle est interne à votre
corps
c'est notamment le carbone 14 contenus
dans vos aliments et puis ça peut être
des tas d'autres éléments radioactifs
que contiennent vos aliments donc un
français c'est 2 5 millisieverts tu par
personne et par an si au lieu d'inviter
à paris vous habitez à la base et bien à
la paz à 4000 mètres d'altitude
vous allez prendre 2 millisieverts par
an à puce aucun médecin
aucune étude épidémiologique ne semble
avoir documenté des faits quelconque
liés à ce surplus de radioactivité vous
pouvez aller habiter à espírito santos
au brésil
je suis sûr que vous en rêvez et à ce
moment vous avez 35 min si verte de plus
par an et là aussi il n'existe pas
d'études médicales documentant un effet
particulier
de ce surplus de la radioactivité
ambiante il faut bien voir que là comme
ailleurs
qu'il s'agisse de la radioactivité du
tabac de l'alcool ou du lsd les gens qui
détiennent la vérité pour savoir si
c'est mauvais ou pas pour la santé c'est
toujours les mêmes c'est la profession
médicale encore les gens dont c'est le
métier de regarder ici une substance à
des effets particuliers sur l'être
humain c'est les médecins ces salles en
métier c'est ça qu'on leur demande alors
les médecins
qu'est-ce qui vous disent quand on
s'intéresse à l'effet des radiations sur
la santé eh bien ils vous disent un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
représentées sur cette courbe la
première chose qui vous disent ce que si
vous irradié quelqu'un à plus de 700
millisieverts tu vous allez voir
apparaître des effets qu'on appelle
déterministe c'est à dire que on sait
parce que la la la la
dommage que vous observez on sait que
les dommages que vous observez sont la
conséquence des rayonnements que vous
avez envoyé et rien d'autre un exemple
dans la cohorte de survivants
d'hiroshima qui a été étudié par les
médecins après les bombardements au
japon il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui ont reçu des irradiations à des
doses significatives qui ont eu ce qu'on
appelle une alopécie stériles ont perdu
leurs cheveux
bon bah ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un
effet déterministe du rayonnement c'est
à dire que à partir de 700 millisieverts
tu vous vous attendez à voir arriver ce
genre de trucs et la gravité de la
conséquence croix avec la dose donc pour
une même personne
plus la dose qu'elle reçoit est
importante et plus la conséquence que
vous allez observer chez elle est grave
ça c'est encore une fois pour des
irradiations qui son supérieur à 700
millisieverts tu si vous avez des
irradiations qui sont inférieures à 2
100 millisieverts chez l'adulte 100
millisieverts che l'enfant et 20
millisieverts chez le foetus vous
observez vous n'observez rien ça veut
dire que si vous prenez deux populations
identique en tout point identique en
tous cas exactement ce qu'on fait pour
le tabac ou l'alcool c'est ce qu'on
appelle une étude
études épidémiologiques donc vous prenez
deux populations identique en tout point
à l'une vous ne faites rien de
particulier vous l'a laissé dans son
fond de radioactivité ambiante naturelle
à trois ou quatre ou cinq ou 10 ou 20
millisieverts par an et à l'autre voulu
rajouter moins de 20 pour un foetus
moins 200 pour un enfant moins de 200
pour un adulte bas vous voyez pas de
différence ça veut dire que tous les
médecins qui ont essayé de faire des
recherches sur ce genre de choses ne
sont jamais arrivés à la conclusion que
il y avait une différence qu'on pouvait
mettre en évidence
bien évidemment ce genre d'étude est
toujours nettement compliquée par le
fait que tous les gens qui meurent ne
disent pas toujours de quoi il meurt que
il faut avoir des accès à des registres
de mortalité qu'il faut travailler sur
des cordes très importante etc
vous avez quand même si vous faites une
recherche dans la littérature médicale
deux cent mille articles qui ont été
publiés avec le bo radionucléides et
3000 articles qui ont été publiés avec
le goût tchernobyl
j'ai fait le test donc y'a quand même
toute une catégorie toute une branche de
la médecine qui consiste à s'intéresser
à l'effet des rayonnements ionisants et
vous avez une littérature abondante
publiées sur le sujet exactement comme
pour la recherche sur le climat
donc là je vous tire les conclusions
essentielles entre 200 et 700
millisieverts tu chez l'adulte
vous allez avoir ce qu'on appelle des
effets statistiques les fosses de
plastique ce que vous avez des
conséquences qui si elles surviennent ne
sont pas proportionnels à la dose reçue
et qui vont survenir en quantité
croissante avec l'irradiation où la
probabilité d'occurrence croix avec les
radiations ses conséquences
en pratique son pôle essentiel ce qu'on
appelle des cancers il s'agisse de
tumeurs solides ou qu'ils s'agissent de
leucémie donc en gros si vous avez une
population et que vous l'irradié à 3 100
millisieverts tu
il ya une fraction de la population qui
à cause de cela va avoir plus de cancers
que si elle n'avait pas reçu irradiation
en question et si vous irradié tout le
monde à 400 vous en aurez encore plus
est à 5 fois encore plus etc
mais ceux qui attrapent le cancer dans
ce genre de circonstances il attrape un
cancer n'est mal le cancer est pas plus
ou moins
grave en fonction de la dose a été reçu
c'est où vous l'avez vous l'avez pas
d'accord c'est binaire alors que les
effets déterministes que vous avez au
dessus de 700 millisieverts vous pouvez
les avoir plus ou moins graves
par exemple les érythèmes vous les avez
plus ou moins les brouilleurs les avait
plus ou moins graves les alopécie vous
les avez plus ou moins graves vous avez
également des effets sur les la muqueuse
intestinale qui du reste fait partie des
effets mortels c'est le plus ou moins
graves
en fonction de la dose reçue dans dans
entre 200 et 700 vous augmenter la
probabilité d'attraper quelque chose
mais si vous la trappe et c'est pas plus
ou moins graves
en fonction de la dose que vous avez
reçue c'est un surplus de cancer que
vous observé dans la population qui a
été irradié
lorsque je suis en train de vous dire
c'est que au dessus de 2 100
millisieverts tu vous avez ce qu'on
appelle des effets avérés c'est à dire
que ont documenté et on sait la
profession médicale compétente sur le
sujet est capable de documenter que je
passe des choses qui se serait passé si
vous n'avez pas une irradiation question
au dessus de 100 millisieverts chez les
adultes
il ya des effets documenté en dessous
jamais rien n'a été mis en évidence par
des études épidémiologiques
donc il ya des effets qui ne sont pas
avérés il ya des effets qui sont
éventuellement hypothétique
peut-être y en a peut-être y en a pas et
s'il y en a une chose est sûre c'est que
l'ampleur de ce qui se produit reste
dans la variabilité naturelle des décès
quand vous n'êtes pas capable de dire là
je constate qu'il ya eu plus de morts et
je suis clairement capables de relier ça
a une cause de d vous êtes capable de
faire ça pour l'alcool vous êtes capable
de faire ça pour le talent est capable
de faire sa prose accident de la route
c'est là pour les rayonnements en
dessous de 100 millisieverts tu
vous n'êtes pas capable cela étant ici
comme ailleurs les autorités de sûreté
nucléaire ont pris une règle qui est une
règle de seine et même d''excellents'
gestion qui est de dire dans le doute je
vais prendre l'hypothèse la plus
défavorable possible pour moi c'est à
dire que je vais demander aux gens de se
comporter comme si à des deux
faible je continuerai à avoir un surplus
de conséquences dans la population avec
une proportionnalité entre la dose reçue
et le surplus hypothétique puisque je
n'ai jamais observé que j'obtiendrais
donc en gros on fait exactement comme
quand on tient des comptes d'une
entreprise et qu'on est prié d'être
prudents c'est à dire de prendre
l'hypothèse la plus défavorable possible
quand on ne sait pas quand on passe une
provision dans les comptes d'une
entreprise c'est exactement la même
chose que vous demande le code de
commerce c'est d'être prudent voilà
c'est pareil les autorités de sûreté on
demande aux gens d'être prudent c'est à
dire de faire comme si on était dans le
cas le plus défavorable possible est le
cas le plus défavorable possible
consiste à prolonger la relation qui
existe au niveau des effets à gré vers
eux en direct droite ça veut donc dire
que là vous êtes ado 100 millisieverts
vous avez des résultats
si vous êtes à 50 vous considérez que
vous avez un quart des résultats vous
faites comme si on avait un quart des
résultats et donc les investissements
que vous allez faire pour éviter à la
population de recevoir ces 50
ils sont basés sur toutes les mers
éviter que vous calculez
hypothétiquement à ce niveau là mais
c'est du calcul
c'est une règle de prudence ça ne
correspondent pas à des morts qui se
constate à regret quand vous essayez de
constater les moeurs peu de vrai
personne n'est capable de les mettre en
évidence et c'est cette règle linéaire
sans seuil qui est à l'origine des
batailles de schiste que vous pouvez
trouver dans la presse généraliste sur
les conséquences de tchernobyl
parce qu'il se trouve que à tchernobyl
les gens qui ont reçu plus de 2 100
millisieverts tu ils se comptent ces
quelques dizaines tous les autres ils
ont reçu n'importe quoi entre 0 et 100
si vous dites à plus de 200 on n'a
jamais rien constaté
donc il a pu y avoir des morts mais pas
à cause des radiations et y en a
sûrement lui à cause d'autres choses
notamment le stress qui a été engendrée
par le fait qu'on ait évacué cent mille
personnes
ça c'est absolument évident que ça a dû
causer des décès mais si vous vous
limitez aux radiations stricto sensu
vous pouvez avoir deux
position la première et dire je
considère qu'il n'y a pas une marque
surnuméraires parce que j'en ai jamais
vu ailleurs à ce niveau de radiation est
la deuxième position est de dire
j'applique la règle de radioprotection
en disant que j'utilise là pour compter
des morts alors que d'habitude on
utilise pour prendre des mesures de
protection et à ce moment vous vous
retrouvez effectivement avec quelques
dizaines de milliers de morts mais que
vous êtes incapable d'observer dans les
statistiques disponibles avec toute la
limite encore une fois et toutes les
précautions qui s'imposent sur les
statistiques disponibles
vous avez même un certain nombre de cas
de figure dans lesquelles les
biologistes ont documenté quelque chose
qui s'apparente à un effet dax 1 c'est à
dire que quand vous bombardez des
cellules avec des très faibles doses
d'accueil que par vous avez une forme de
darwinisme qui s'applique et ça rend
l'organisme plutôt plus aptes à résister
à des irradiations un peu supérieure
voilà il semblerait qu'ils aient
quelques tapes figure dans lequel on est
documenté ce genre d'effets de leur
visite et que vous avez représenté ici
par la très verte pour finir là-dessus
retenez quand même une chose c'est que
au niveau de deux choses auxquelles on
ne parle pour tchernobyl où l'essentiel
des gens pour lesquels on a évalué parce
que je vous en parlais juste après la
dose qu'ils ont reçus parce qu'on n'a
pas mesuré
on va évaluer ça reste inférieur à ce
qu'on prend quand on va passer un
scanner un scanner ça peut monter
jusqu'à 80 mille ici verte en terme de
radiation
la quasi totalité des gens qui se
trouvaient dans la zone interdite autour
de tchernobyl ont pris moins que 80
millisieverts ta cause de l'accident
alors je vais pas en train de vous dire
qu'il faut que ça se reproduise tous les
jours je suis juste en train d'essayer
d'illustrer un point parce que dans leur
vie professionnelle on vous demandera
enfin je l'espère d'être un minimum
rigoureux c'est que à toute rigueur en
toute rigueur vous n'avez pas de
démonstration implacable qui vous
permettent d'attribuer à tchernobyl quoi
que ce soit de supérieur aux effets
déterministes que j'ai évoqués et est
une
très particulière dont je vais parler un
peu plus tard également pour la france
qui est des cancers la thyroïde chez les
enfants ou là vous avez des cascio
numéraire et là très clairement vous
n'êtes pas dans vous n'êtes pas dans la
variabilité naturelle
donc vous avez quelques milliers de
cancers à la thyroïde quelques dizaines
de dessins à bref délai pour des causes
déterministe et peu le reste personne
n'est capable de documenter quoi que ce
soit nous dans le sens de la rien de
plus
évidemment ni dans le sens de la hutte
et en plus c'est ça c'est ça le sait ça
le constat qu'il faut garder présent à
l'esprit alors je vous disais tout à
l'heure
la deux a été évalué bah oui l'a10 a été
évalué le seul moyen d'être absolument
certain que quelqu'un a pris une dose
donner c'est de faire porter un
dosimètre donc si certains d'entre vous
sont déjà allés dans les installations
du ce1 ou ont été visité une centrale
nucléaire touchée pas quoi on vous met
un petit dosimètres quand vous rentrez
dans l'installation et puis on vérifie
quand vous sortez que vous n'avez pas
reçu trop de radiation il est bien
évident que les 5 millions de personnes
les 5 millions relative de trois doigts
typhon vers la poubelle
il est bien évident que les 5 millions
de personnes qui ont été dans ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la zone contaminée
n'avait pas de dosimètre sur elle en
avait pas donc déjà la dose que ces gens
ont reçu n'est pas le résultat d'une
mesure c'est le résultat d'un calcul
déjà ça c'est le résultat d'un calcul
le calcul se base sur la reconstitution
la reconstitution de la trajectoire des
éléments radioactifs qui se sont
échappées du réacteur et aujourd'hui on
fait des émanations sur les retombées
par exemple césium 137 qui est un des
produits de fission qui va durer
quelques dizaines d'années
eh bien les
retombée il peut y avoir qui se mesure
en kilos becquerels par mètre carré en
train de créer donc j'ai oublié de vous
dire ça c'est une désintégration
atomique par seconde
c'est une unité qui est microscopique
qu'enfin elle n'est même pas une grosse
copie qu'elle est plus que microscopique
chacun d'entre vous vous êtes victime ou
l'objet moi je veux dire d'une
radioactivité propre qui est de 7000
becquerels par ce biais de ses piles
décret lu par don de 5000 désintégration
par seconde dans notre corps en corps de
chacun d'entre vous j'ai sept mille
désintégration par seconde
ça nous empêche pas de vivre à quelques
dizaines d'années un qui le granit s'est
également quelques minutes de créer
cette personne dans un ascenseur ses
quarante mille de crédit redecard d'un
quand vous voyez dans la grande presse
des chiffres en becquerel un peu vous de
ce que c'est qu'un becquerels si je
mesure est allé en manque cruel vous
allez très très grand voilà c'est un peu
pareil si j'utilise le b trail pour
mesurer la radioactivité
je ne sais tout de suite impressionné
avec des nombres à cette sérieux qui en
fait représentent des trucs absolument
microscopique donc j'insiste à ce stade
essentiellement sur le fait que la
contamination que de l'environnement que
absolument qui existe c'est à dire qu'il
ya des traces des sables et le bez qui
ont été reçus par les individus font
l'objet de calculs et non pas de mesure
c'est le résultat de calculs et non pas
de mesure exactement comme pour les
membres dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est l'application d'une règle
de radioprotection qui normalement n'a
rien à faire là et ça n'est absolument
pas les faits constatés et documentée de
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
alors je vous ai dit que tchernobyl
avait eu en effet particulièrement bien
documentée qui était celui de le d'avoir
augmenté sa s'est par contre tout à fait
documenter les cancers à la thyroïde
chez les enfants donc ça concerne les
gens qui étaient enfants au moment de
l'accident de la centrale
ça n'a pas concerné les adultes en
france
vous avez également une augmentation du
nombre de cancers à la thyroïde chez les
adultes que vous voyez ici
si matérialisée par les courbes
violettes et vertes ce qu'on appelle
l'incidence c'est à dire le taux pour
cent mille personnes de cancer à la
thyroïde et vous voyez que c'est quelque
chose qui augmente depuis l'année 1975
c'est à dire très exactement onze ans
avant l'accident de tchernobyl
alors après ça se discute peut-être
avant ça se discute quand même beaucoup
moins paraît assez peu probable que
l'accident a eu des effets rétroactifs
est en fait vous voyez que au moment où
l'accident a lieu la dérive et des pas
modifié ce qui veut dire que a priori ce
qui se passe en france est totalement
décorrélée buzz qui s'est passé chez les
ukrainiens
en fait vous avez ici une courbe qui est
beaucoup plus de résultats de quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
tchernobyl que sont les deux paramètres
suivants
et ça c'est quelque chose que je sais ce
que je vais vous dire vous pouvez
l'extrapoler à n'importe quelles
conséquences sanitaires dans à peu près
n'importe quel domaine
c'est aussi vrai dans bon enfin je veux
dire c'est ce que je vais vous expliquer
ces des facteurs qui contribuent à
briller la vision dans des tas d'autres
domaines et pas seulement dans celui que
je vais vous évoquez tout de suite vous
avez bonne chose qui s'appelle d'une
part l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
et d'autre part les biens de dépistage
qui font que vous pouvez très bien avoir
ce genre de courbes sans que quoi que ce
soit d'échanger dans l'environnement
alors l'allongement de l'espérance de
vie
c'est tout simplement que vous laissez
un certain nombre de cancers le temps de
se développer alors qu avant ils
n'avaient pas le temps de se développer
parce que vous m'auriez plus jeunes
d'autres choses à les exemples pardon
messieurs ces cancers de la prostate
il se trouve que si vous faites le top-6
d'une personne qui est morte à 80 ans
écrasée par une voiture d'hyperthermie
d'un infarctus ou en se noyant et bien
vous allez trouver dans un nombre
significatif de cage puis chief en tête
des des noyaux cancéreux dans la
prostate
voilà sauf que d'habitude vous n'allez
pas chercher parce que la personne est
morte deux choses mais si vous allez
cherchez vous en trouvez dans une
fraction chez un nombre
c'est dans une proportion non nul
dm qui meurt ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
la conséquence de l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie voilà donc vous avez
des trucs qui se développe alors
qu'avance à se développer par savait pas
dire que si vous trouvez plus c'est
nécessairement la conséquence de
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie ça
veut simplement dire que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs
cette simple cause peut avoir des
conséquences dans le sens de
l'augmentation de l'incidence d'un
certain nombre de cancers
la deuxième cause c'est la deuxième
chose qui peut expliquer pardon ce genre
d'évolution
c'est ce qu'on appelle les biens
dépistage c'est à dire que vous avez des
moyens de dépistage dont les
performances augmentent dont vous avez
plus de gens malades simplement vous
avez de meilleur moyen de savoir ce qui
concerne les cancers de la thyroïde
il se trouve que les moyens de dépistage
permettent de repérer des nodules de
plus en plus petit donc donc un certain
nombre d'entre vous chez qui on n'aurait
rien trouvé avec les moyens dada et qui
se répand d'autres choses de manière
parfaitement naturel et bien on va en
trouver simplement parce que les moyens
d'investigation se sont améliorées et
ce2 les deux éléments dont je viens de
vous parler complique énormément la
tâche des médecins des qui veulent faire
une attribution de cause à effet parce
que le monde est multi déterminée et
isoler une seule cause qui est celle à
laquelle on s'intéresse en particulier
en ce qui concerne les effets de la
radioactivité et en particulier en ce
qui concerne les effets qui se déclenche
au bout de 20 à 30 ou 40 ans est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement difficile
alors donc c'est ça sa ferme le chapitre
sur les effets sur la santé dans le
cadre de l'exploitation normale ce que
reçoivent les travailleurs du nucléaire
quelques millisieverts par an ou même
quelques dizaines de millisieverts par
an ça reste de l'ordre de grandeur de ce
qui est parfaitement tolérable par le
corps humain
là aussi il ya une chose qui ne faut pas
une erreur qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
de penser que tout se mesure à des
mauvais quelque chose que on a souvent
tendance à faire c'est de penser que
tout ce qui se mesure est nécessairement
toxiques et du reste
ça peut vous paraître idiot mais ce
genre de réflexe entre guillemets est à
l'origine souvent du durcissement de la
réglementation en matière
environnementale c'est à dire que l'anem
suit la sensibilité des appareils de
mesure sans qu'on se demande
nécessairement si c'est un sens toute
cette affaire de durcir la
réglementation je fais un petit
incidente
en ce qui concerne le plomb dans l'eau
de boisson au teneur de plomb que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans l'autre boissons
le est devenue un mode d'ingestion
parfaitement secondaire du plomb c'est
en général les aliments qui sont devenus
le vote dominant donc si on change tous
les tuyaux en plomb ce qui va avoir un
coup absolument considérable ça va
mobiliser beaucoup d'argent
eh bien ça ne changera pas de manière
significative la quantité de plomb que
nous ingérons et qui est de toute façon
significativement inférieur à ce qui
déclenche des effets sanitaires très
désagréable il n'empêche que la norme
fas les normes européennes sur les
teneurs maximales admissibles en plomb
dans l'eau de boisson ont une certaine
tendance à suivre la sensibilité des
appareils de mesure voilà donc plus
d'appareils de mesures deviennent
sensibles et plus envie qu'il va falloir
gagner un facteur 10 sur le truc alors
qu'aujourd'hui la quasi totalité des
médecins à qui vous posez la question
vous disent que ça va pas d'incident
sanitaires donc c'est celle à la fin
encore une fin de la parenthèse sur la
santé pour le travail irrégulier
c'est a priori il ya très peu de
d'inconvénients il y en a en tout cas
considérablement moins qu'avec le
charbon le gaz pour les travailleurs en
situation normale le charbon fait chaque
année et quelques milliers de morts dans
les mines
je vous laisse imaginer ce que vous
liriez dans le journal c'est nucléaire
civile faisait chaque année quelques
milliers de morts là où il est exploité
je pense que vous entendriez un peu plus
parlé et quand vous avez une une usine
de liquéfaction du gaz qui explosent en
algérie vous avez un petit machin comme
ça en bas à droite dans le journal et
puis on va parle plus ça a beau avoir
fait dix vingt trente ou quarante morts
voilà c'est dans la rubrique chiens
écrasés
et puis derrière c'est terminé c'est
c'est encore une fois le candidat les
effets documenté et la couverture
médiatique de genre de sujets ne sont
pas toujours en relation
quand vous avez un accident il y en a eu
un
c'est quelque chose de très emmerdant
très objectivement la conséquence la
plus ennuyeuse et probablement la
stérilisation exactement la non
disponibilité des terres pour des usages
agricoles pendant n'importe quoi entre
50 et 100 ans parce que les
radionucléides voir leur tendance à se
concentrer dans certaines plantes
cultivées et là ils peuvent commencer à
devenir en continent mais il est faux de
dire que ça fait des centaines de
milliers ou des millions de morts par
effets des radiations
maintenant il ya une autre question qui
se pose qui est ce que le nucléaire
civil permet d'arriver à des dispositifs
qui le font des centaines de milliers de
morts parce qu'ils sont prévues pour ça
ou pas une partie de la réponse positive
une partie de la réponse est positive
parce que une fois vous avez appris à
des ingénieurs ou à des physiciens
affaires de l'anneau chronique à faire
de la physique nucléaire à faire et
c'est à ben les connaissances
scientifiques qu'ils ont dans un domaine
à ils peuvent les exploiter pour un
domaine b il ya donc un certain nombre
de bases scientifiques qui sont communes
tous les raffinements techniques ne sont
pas mais il ya quand même un nombre de
bases scientifiques commune
c'est absolument indiscutable il est
possible d'accéder aux matières fissiles
qui vont servir dans un réacteur
nucléaire avec des dispositifs qui
peuvent aussi servir à faire des
matières fissiles qui pourront être
utilisés pour des armements actuellement
en fait ce qui peut nous le plus de
problèmes dans la prolifération
c'est moins les centrales elles mêmes
que ceux qui permet de fabriquer le
combustible
si vous avez un peu suivi l'actualité
vous savez qu'on a actuellement des
démêlés avec l'iran qui a construit des
dispositifs d'enrichissement de
l'uranium et que 2k accuse d'avoir
construit ces dispositifs
avec comme arrière pensée très
l'air de vouloir fabriquer un armement
nucléaire et de fait avec les
centrifugeuses qu'ils ont si vous si
vous enrichissez pas beaucoup vous
faites du combustible nucléaire
si vous enrichissez énormément vous
faites du pardon vous êtes combustible
de civils si vous enrichissez énormément
fait du combustible militaire c'est
beaucoup plus long mais vous arrivez
quand même vous avez également des
filières électrogène qui sont trop
différentes
c'était un derby mk soviétique
en fait là dont le dessin initial du
réacteur qui a explosé à tchernobyl
il y avait dans le cahier des charges la
possibilité de pouvoir retirer du
plutonium encore de fonctionnement il ya
également cette possibilité même si je
ne sais pas si elle a été aussi froid
que ça on sait que les indiens sont pas
servis de faire la même chose avec les
conduit donc d un concept canadien qui
permet de fonctionner à l'uranium
naturel
par contre dans certains réacteurs par
contre le fait d'avoir des centrales
elle-même la filière de production du
combustible peut être un facteur de
prolifération
la centrale elle-même à l'exception des
contenus c'est beaucoup plus rare et
c'est beaucoup plus rare pour une
première raison qui est que vous avez vu
tout à l'heure que pour avoir une
exploitation commerciale intéressant
d'un combustible nucléaire il faut le
laisser quelques années à l'intérieur de
la centrale si vous devez de charger
décharger tous les quinze jours
commercialement ça marche pas bien enfin
je veux dire le prix de votre
kilowattheure a qu'un pas exactement le
même
or peut faire du plutonium 239 dans deux
du combustible nucléaire donc à partir
d'uranium 238 faut pas le laisser
longtemps dans le réacteur
parce que si vous le laissez longtemps
dans le réacteur une partie de ce
plutonium 239 va absorber des neutrons
et se transformer en plutonium de 140
puis se transforme également en
plutonium 241 et ses essais isotopes là
ils sont pas de bonne qualité militaire
d'abord les isotopes père ils sont pas
fils il est le plus tôt net de 141 par
exemple pose des problèmes techniques
que vous n'avez pas être plus taille 1
239 donc les réacteurs normes eux ils se
prêtent pas facilement à la
prolifération
encore une fois ce qui se prêtent
beaucoup plus facilement la
prolifération c'est la filière
r qui permet de produire le combustible
maintenant il ya quelques petites choses
qu'il faut garder en tête la première
c'est que malheureusement pour nous on
n'a pas besoin de nucléaire civil pour
proliférer et non seulement on en
apprend que c'est à dire acquérir des
armes militaires mais des armes
nucléaires pardon mais non seulement on
en a pas besoin de nucléaire civil
mais la quasi-totalité des pays qui se
sont à un moment de leur histoire dotés
d'armement nucléaire
même s'ils ne les ont plus aujourd'hui
c'est le cas par exemple de l'afrique du
sud qui avait la bombe et qui l'a
démontré eh bien ils l'ont fait sans
passer par l'étape réacteurs civils qui
sont venus ensuite la quasi totalité des
pays ont eu la boule qui ont la bombe
ont la bombe avant d'avoir des réacteurs
civils
donc le déterminant de l'acquisition
d'armes nucléaires ne pas le fait de
vouloir faire de l'électricité à partir
d'uranium
c'est autre chose et quand vous regardez
quand vous prenez une lecture historique
de l'acquisition à la bombe atomique
vous vous rendez compte que le premier
déterminant c'est de vouloir s'affirmer
comme puissance mondiale ou régionale
les etats-unis ont fabriqué la bombe
quand c'était un pays en guerre
donc ils l'ont fabriquée à un moment où
le but du jeu c'était d'être puissant la
première puissance mondiale à la voir
les soviétiques l'ont fait ensuite parce
qu'il s'agissait d'affirmer leur
capacité à être à égalité avec les
américains regardez les discours tenus
par de gaulle pour que la france accède
à la bombe
c'est pareil ce sont des discours
d'affirmation de la souveraineté et de
la puissance du pays est aujourd'hui les
quelques pays qui veulent accéder à la
bombe ou qu'ils ont déjà et qui veulent
que ça se reconnaissent ou qui et cetera
sont deux pays qui veulent exister en
tant que puissance régionale
c'est le cas de l'irak c'est le cas de
l'iran voilà c'est ces pays là ont des
souhaits en cours pour exister en tant
que puissance régionale
ça veut dire cette affaire que on peut
bien vraisemblablement supprimer le
nucléaire civil
chez les russes chez les a
eric 1 et chez nous il est assez peu
probable que ça modifiera quoi que ce
soit dans l'angle dans ma vie alors les
facultés matériel ne sais pas mais dans
la vie d'accéder à la bombe
si nous on va conserver une des iraniens
ou des irakiens ou d'un certain nombre
d'autres pays dans le monde
donc encore une fois la prolifération
c'est une technique qui restera
disponible parce que maintenant que les
gens là possèdent elles restent quelque
part dans les labos et un souhait
d'affirmation de sa puissance et ça
n'est absolument pas le fait de vouloir
faire de l'électricité
en fait le fait de faire de
l'électricité à partir de l'atome est
une situation qui est quelque part
plutôt plus confortable quand les gens
ont déjà les technologies nucléaires que
ne pas le faire parce que s'il commence
à construire des centrales
les centrales ces gros ça se surveillent
facilement de ce pass vous voyez ce qui
rend plus qui sort donc en fait ne gros
paradoxe c'est que quand vous commencez
à avoir des centrales est bien quelque
part vous vous mettez dans un dispositif
vous êtes plus facile à surveiller que
si vous faites la bombe dans notre coin
sans avoir de centrales alalala le côté
comment dire étonnante cette affaire
c'est que dès lors que vous avez des
centrales mais finalement c'est plus
visible une centrale que pas de
centrales et donc vous êtes quelque part
plus facile à surveiller et puis en plus
b que vous avez une centrale le reste de
la communauté des nations on va vous
demander de rentrer dans le cadre de la
hjra c'est à dire du du cadre
international dans lequel vous acceptez
vous prenez des engagements de contrôle
de ce qui se passe chez vous 1 vous
acceptez la communauté internationale
contrôlent ce qui se passe chez vous et
si vous refusez il vous arrive ce qui se
passe pour la corée du nord où il vous
arrive ce qui se passe pour dans une
moindre mesure pour l'iran la corée du
nord c'est vraiment très triste pour
elle parce qu'elle n'a pas de pétrole
donc a vraiment aucune arme de rétorsion
l'iran s'est un peu moindre mais en 12
heures il vous arrive que dans les
négociations commerciales ben finalement
vous avez un handicap
donc le
l'existence d'installations civile au
sein d'un pays qui maîtrise déjà la
technologie nucléaire est plutôt une
bonne chose à tout prendre qu'une
mauvaise
voilà donc tout ça ça c'est pour vous
dire que le débat sur l'apport je prends
la question de savoir le débat sur la
prolifération est un débat compliqué
dans lequel malheureusement quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe on peut pas se
contenter de l'argument qui consiste à
dire il ya une centrale donc les gens
ont fait un boom malheureusement c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
non très peu la corée du nord avait un
réacteur plus tôt dizaine donc la l1
fait un peu de production d'électricité
avec mais c'était clairement un réacteur
qui étaient destinés à faire du
plutonium de qualité militaire d'entrée
de jeu je sais plus si l'inde le
pakistan à parité a pas proliférer cette
manière mais ces îles sont ils sont très
rares israël n'avait pas d'installation
civile l'afrique du sud n'avait pas
d'installation civile il ya un péril un
pays d'amérique latine qui commençait à
avoir des velléités sur le brésil je
crois et qu'il n'a fait qu'y a des
ventes et du reste lui-même sans son
programme donc l'essentiel des pays ils
ont d'abord eu la bombe puis eu des
centrales dans ce sens là que ça s'est
passé je vous ai fait on pourrait le
passé deux heures un bref panorama des
inconvénients et de quelques éléments
d'appréciation des inconvénients qu'on
peut avoir
maintenant finalement je vais m'attaquer
ce qui à mes yeux le principal
inconvénient du nucléaire qui est encore
une fois tout simplement le fait qu'on
chauffe les oiseaux avec l'essentiel de
l'énergie qu'on produit sur la partie de
gauche vous avez les réacteurs actuels
où vous avez une température de
fonctionnement à l'intérieur du coeur
qui est de quelques centaines de
vêtements dans le circuit de la peur de
quelques centaines de degrés et avec ce
genre de température bas monsieur car de
il vous dit que vous pouvez espérer des
rendements de l'ordre du tiers en ce qui
concerne la partie électrique et le
reste encore je vous disais tout à
l'heure par dans les petits oiseaux
un certain nombre de physiciens se sont
dit que ce genre de concept c'était pas
intéressant et qu'il y avait d'autres
choses dans le nucléaire actuel qui
rendait le nucléaire pas intéressant
entre guillemets ou plus exactement
notoirement sous employés alors les
choses que les physiciens aimerait bien
corrigés sont les suivantes
la première chose c'est qu'ils
voudraient que le combustible soit ce
qu'on appelle en cycle fermé
c'est à dire que le réacteur brûle ses
propres déchets donc en d'autres termes
ce qui sort du réacteur c'est que le
truc
ne présente quasiment pas de problème de
traitement particulier le deuxième point
qu'ils aimeraient bien avoir ces
utiliser mieux l'énergie produite à
l'intérieur du réacteur alors il ya deux
manières de mieux l'utiliser c'est ou
bien vous utilisez beaucoup mieux
l'énergie qui est déjà disponible par la
fission de l'uranium 235 par exemple en
montant à des températures beaucoup plus
élevé parce que comme ça vous pouvez
récupérer une fraction beaucoup plus
importante de l'énergie produite ou bien
en élargissant les noyaux qui sont enfin
là bas des loyauté est accessible et
donc en travaillant soit avec l'uranium
238 pour en faire du plutonium soit avec
le thorium 232 pour en faire du radium
233 et puis tant qu'ils y étaient ils
sont dit que ça serait aussi bien
d'avoir des réacteurs avec ce qu'on
appelle des sécurité passive
c'est-à-dire que s'il ya quoi que ce
soit qui se met à aller de travers dans
le réacteur il n'y a pas de réactions
critiques possibles
d'accord le système s'effondre de lui
même mais s'effondre au sens de voilà ça
s'arrête et puis on n'en parle plus un
exemple si vous utilisez comme
modérateur de l'eau qui est également le
cas nous porter si jamais vous avez une
fuite dans le circuit
la première chose qui va se passer c'est
que votre on va rentrer en ébullition
donc il va rester dans la peur dans le
circuit et la vapeur ça permet toujours
de modérer les deux troncs qui se balade
et à ce moment vous pouvez avoir les
excursions de puissance et votre truc à
qui il arrive des envies si vous
utilisez un gaz et que le gaz donc il
est dimensionné pour servir à la fois de
caloporteur et de modérateur et que le
circuit serait à fuir et bien plus le
circuit fuis-moi vous avez gaz - vous
avez gaz moins de deux tronçons modéré
et moins les nôtres sont modérés et plus
la réaction commence à
comment ça fait rire d'elle-même donc ça
c'est par exemple un système dans lequel
vous avez une femme de sécurité passive
c'est-à-dire que si vous avez un
accident qui arrive au coeur de votre
réacteurs l'évolution de la réaction en
chaîne sépaq s'emballer c2c de mourir
alors toutes ses caractéristiques que je
viens de vous évoquez c'est le cahier
des charges de ce qu'on appelle la
génération 4 qu'aucun génération iv est
là dans son cahier des charges de mieux
exploiter de combustible et notamment de
s'attaquer au noyau fertile si elle peut
de mieux d'avoir de meilleurs rendements
de générer plus ou quasiment plus de
déchets et j'oubliais un dernier point
d'être le moins proliférante possible ça
veut dire que à aucun moment dans le
cycle du combustible
vous ne donnez vous retrouver avec des
matières très purifier qui pourrait
avoir une exploitation militaire
éventuelle
il est évident qu'on vous retraités
combustible aujourd'hui le combustible
usé sortie des centrales à eau
pressurisée à la main quand vous allez
isolé plutonium
quand vous isolez plutonium même si le
plutonium consorts a pas quelques années
du radiation n'est pas de qualité
militaire
vous avez quand même quelque chose qu'il
ne faut pas laisser entre toutes les
mains la dent cahier des charges de la
génération 4 des physiciens aimerait
bien aussi qu' il n'y ait pas le
caractère proliférant alors ils se sont
mis à la planche à dessin et ils ont
sorti un certain nombre de on dirait des
machines de shadocks dessins de deux
réacteurs qui sont pour partie la remise
au goût du jour de dessins qui ont
fonctionné en france
vous savez qu'en france il ya deux
surgénérateur qui existent ou qui ont
existé qui s'appelle super phénix et
superphénix phoenix et un réacteur de
recherches il a fonctionné pendant des
dizaines d'années
il est temps il est proche de l'arrêt ou
je sais pas si la reine a déjà été
décidée ou ici et c'est mes enfants
conscients fonctionné pendant des
dizaines d'années sans problème
particulier sera marchait très bien
et en ce qui concerne superphénix la
décision d'arrêt n'a pas été liée à
l'impossibilité de faire fonctionner le
réacteur
le prototype qu'il avait été construit à
mieux fonctionner toutes choses égales
par ailleurs que les prototypes des
séries qui avaient précédé donc en gros
super phénix a mieux marché
il a fonctionné plus beurre sur la plage
de temps où il a fonctionné
il a fonctionné plus d'heures sans panne
que le prototype de la génération des
réacteurs à eau pressurisée
donc ce n'était pas des raisons
techniques qui ont fait qu'il a été
arrêté c'est parce que le pouvoir qui
est arrivé à ce moment là a dit ben
finalement ça nous plaît plus la couleur
est une partie de la génération 4
revient à mettre au goût du jour
superphénix ou quelque chose qui y
ressemble
le dessin superphénix et ça c'est un
réacteur rapide au sodium au sodium ça
veut dire que lequel au porteur qui est
aussi un modérateur
parce que c'est des noyaux légers c'est
du sodium fondu avec le sodium fondu ne
plaît pas à tout le monde avec pote avec
de vraies raisons qui s'habille vente et
c'est un réacteur rapide parce que vous
allez fissionner du plutonium donc qui
utilisent des neutrons rapides ici vous
avez d'amiante dans lequel le calot par
terre c'est du plus du plomb fondu mais
c'est un dessin qui aujourd'hui pose des
problèmes au niveau de la cohésion en
particulier exercée par le plomb fondu
dans les tuyaux ici vous avez un
réacteur rapide à gaz
alors c'est toujours pareil ça utilise
le cycle uranium plutonium enfin le
couple uranium plutonium et le
caloporteur qui est aussi le modérateur
est à gaz
ici vous avez la même chose sauf que je
sais pas si ça thermique ou en rapide
avec de la très haute température est la
très haute température comme je vous le
dit tout à l'heure a un avantage c'est
que ça permet d'avoir un rendement qui
est bien meilleur plus à température du
coeur ont été levées
et plus le rendement est élevé aussi là
vous avez un réacteur à l'eau
supercritique ça veut dire que vous avez
mis une telle pression que les devenu
super critique dont vous avez plus de
phases l'équipe vapeur c'est terminé et
ici vous avez un concept un peu
futuriste qui est un réacteur à sels
fondus dans l'automne le caloporteur est
l'élément fils ils sont mélangés dans
j'allais dire dans la marmite
vous avez un liquide unique qui contient
à la fois l'élément fissiles et le
téléporteur et notamment c'est un dessin
qui est explorée avec des sels de
thorium et qui aurait un certain nombre
davantage de celui d'être extrêmement
peu pro différent parce que vous
travaillez avec un mélange dans lequel a
le cas moment l'élément fils il n'est
t'isoler chimiquement c'est évidemment
très confortable si on veut que quelque
chose soit pas trop différent
alors tous ces dessins ils sont l'objet
d'une recherche qui est mené dans table
d'un consortium international qui
s'appelle le consortium génération iv
les divers pays qui participent à ce
consortium ne finance pas de la même
manière tous les prototypes mais enfin
tout le dessin plus exactement mais ils
donnent tous un peu d'argent les
quantités d'argent qui sont mises sur la
table ces deux là de quelques milliards
de dollars par an donc c'est pas grand
chose au regard du pib mondial qui ont
fait pas loin de 40 milles et si on
considère choses encore une fois pour
laquelle on pourrait avoir un long débat
que le nucléaire est une fraction
significative de la solution aux deux
problèmes de l'épuisement des
combustibles fossiles et du changement
climatique
il est assez vraisemblable que quelques
milliards de dollars ça pourrait être
porté à un peu plus cela autant vous
allez débattre tant que vous avez du mal
à raccourcir dans ce genre de recherche
parce que le chemin par lequel vous
devez passer pour construire des
réacteurs qui génère de l'électricité de
manière industrielle
ça veut donc dire qu'il doit pas coûter
trop cher par rapport à ce qu'ils font
comme électricité
vous avez un certain nombre de points de
passage obligé qui sont très difficiles
à éviter et en particulier vous avez
deux points de passage obligé qui
s'appelle le prototype et la tête de
série qui sont assez difficiles à éviter
je vous en parlerai après quand je
finirai sur la fusion le prototype c'est
la première fois on vous construisez un
appareil qui correspond aux plans vous
avez fait et vous verrez c'est que ça
marche
d'accord donc par exemple super phénix
était un prototype en fonction explique
doctement était un prototype de
surgénérateur voilà il ya des physiciens
qui se sont dit tiens ça sur le papier
ça marche
donc je construis un appareil je vérifie
que ça marche une fois que vous avez
bien ici que ça marche au niveau du
prototype le prototype qui a il y avoir
des tas de trucs qui sont allé de
travers c'est fait pour ça c'est fait
pour essuyer les plâtres
donc vous avez là le clapet de
bidouillage de machin qui s'ouvre pas
exactement quand il faut vous avez la
pression de vapeur ici qui est pas
exactement celle qu'il faut vous avez
été à et dont vous corriger tous ces
trucs là est la copie corrigée
vous construisez une deuxième version
qui s'appelle une tête de série la tête
de série ça veut dire la normale manger
repérer tout ce qui va pas et je
construis quelque chose qui devrait
aller sur à peu près tous les plans vous
faites fonctionner cette tête de série
c'est l'équivalent de le p r pour la
génération iii vous faites fonctionner
cette tête de série vous vous donnez une
durée de retour suffisante pour
apprécier tous ceux qui ne se détectent
pendant une semaine parce que vous avez
des effets vieillissement vous avez et
cetera notamment dans la résistance aux
comportements neutronique donc vous
attendez un peu pour vérifier que tout
ça tient bien la route et c'est
seulement à ce moment là que vous
commencez à faire du déploiement
industriel de votre solution
donc vous avez un dessin vous
construisez le prototype 10 ans parce
qu'une centrale nucléaire c'est un peu
plus long à construire une machine à
café vous faites fonctionner notre
prototype quelques années pour avoir dû
être recul suffisante vous corriger ce
qui doit être corrigé
vous construisez votre tête de série 35
à 10 ans supplémentaires vous prenez
encore quelques années de recul pour
vérifier que tout va bien avant de
commencer le déploiement industriel ce
qui fait qu'un programme nucléaire sur
un nouveau dessin entre le moment où
vous y réfléchissez et le moment où
votre truc et commercialement
disponibles à large échelle
il se passe n'importe quoi entre 20 et
40 ans ce qui est dur et qu'on aille à
veut dire que ce que je vous ai raconté
dans les cours précédent sur le pic de
production du pétrole ne sera en rien
affectée
ce qu'on va faire sur la génération 4 ça
peut être une très bonne idée de mettre
un peu plus de milliards sur la
génération 4 ça ne changera pas la
trajectoire énergétique des pays
développés dans les 20 ans qui viennent
c'est pas la peine de compter là dessus
ce qui fait qu'on a ramené les problèmes
précédents si on y célèbre maxime de mon
école où je vous rappelle que le
problème à résoudre
et celui là c'est à dire comment passer
de cette trajectoire énergétique à cette
trajectoire énergétique et la question
est bien évidemment de savoir à la fin
de ce cours sur le nucléaire
si le nucléaire est effectivement
capable d'encaisser une croissance de 4
à 5% par an de sa production sans
inconvénient majeur ou sans inconvénient
supérieur à ce qui est censé nous éviter
alors voici quelques éléments de
réflexion conclusif que je livre à votre
sagacité la partie dangerosité sanitaire
quand vous mettez en perspective les
conséquences possibles du changement
climatique et les conséquences possibles
de la version up des désagréments on
peut avoir en recourant à l'énergie
nucléaire mais ne semble pas en tout cas
à moi de nature à dire qu'il ne faut pas
recourir à cette solution
combien de tchernobyl aurait fait vingt
mille bâbords je pense que le changement
que je pense que 5% du changement
climatique ça fera bien plus que ça donc
c'est à mon avis quelque chose qui me
dans la balance n'est pas nécessairement
une raison pour s'en débarrasser la
voiture ça fait un million de morts par
an à la surface de la planète et jamais
personne n'a réclamé l'éradication de la
voiture et je suis pas sûr que dans
cette salle vous souhaiterez nombreux à
la vouloir
à cause de ça de même que je suis pas
sûr que vous soyez très nombreux dans
cette salle à vouloir l'éradication de
l'alcool de soirées étudiantes au motif
que ça fait quelques billon morts par an
à la surface de la planète donc dire que
parce que quand le jean decon l'accident
fait quelques milliers de morts c'est un
motif suffisant pour s'en passer
je pense que ça peut vous paraître
brutale mais ça se discute en ce qui
concerne les déchets là aussi il faut
mettre ça en perspective les énergies
fossiles produisent un décès
un déchet pardon mais c'est aussi plus
un qui s'appelle du co2 c'est un déchet
parce qu'on sait pas quoi en faire et sa
part dans l'atmosphère où ça a des
effets non pas chimiques mais physique
la question des réserves est un vrai
sujet à l'échelle de quelques décennies
sur l'uranium 235 cesse d'être un sujet
à l'échelle de quelques décennies si on
passe sur la surgénération il n'empêche
que les limites ou les inconvénients
plus exactement techniques invoqués je
suis pas sûr qu'ils soient majeurs
par contre il ya une limite qui elle est
très importante qui la limite économique
parce que si vous voulez faire 4 % de
croissance sur le nucléaire
ça veut dire que vous avez avoir 2500
réacteurs contre 400 aujourd'hui en 2050
et puis si vous considérez que on
électrifie un certain nombre d' usage
qui ne sont pas électrifiés aujourd'hui
avec des pertes seront à voir avec des
pertes oui parce qu'il va falloir se
cogner la perte primaire finale
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup moins avec les
énergies fossiles
à ce moment vous doublez et si en plus
vous considérez ce qui sera évidemment
la question qu'on va se poser la
prochaine fois que les énergies
renouvelables ne pourront pas faire 4 %
de croissance par an de manière globale
d'ici à 2050 et que c'est
essentiellement le nucléaire qui se
chargent de ce genre de choses
alors il faut un gay à 10000 réacteurs
en service à la surface de la planète en
actuellement vous avez donc 450
réacteurs nucléaires vous devez avoir
quelques milliers de tranches à charbon
de ville 3000 je sais pas exactement
combien voilà est ce qu'on a envie de
faire dix mille réacteurs nucléaires
alors loin de savoir est ce qu'on a
envie c'est ce qu'on en a la possibilité
économique est ce que il y aura des gens
pour le faire tourner est ce que il y
aura les endroits pour les installer
alors ça c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser pour n'importe quelle centrale
électrique
simplement si on électrifie à nombre
croissant d'usagers qui sont aujourd'hui
assurées par les combustibles fossiles
et que ses centrales électriques on
commence par faire bouillir de l'eau
pour faire l'électricité il faut des
sources froides alors il ya des gens qui
sont amusés à faire
q du nombre de l'intervalle qui séparait
de centrales si on met tout ça en bord
de mer effectivement ils sont arrivés à
la conclusion que quand vous allez au
festival du film américain à deauville
vous en verrez deux ou trois de la plage
moi je vais chez pull et j'ai pu les
chiffres en tête mais bon ça c'est une
vraie question
ça se serait posé avec autre chose dès
lors que vous électrifié beaucoup d'
usage et enfin vous avez vu les très
longs délais qui sont la caractéristique
de la mise en route d'un problème
nucléaire en france par exemple entre le
moment où on a décidé de faire un
programme nucléaire civil
et le moment où le dernier réacteurs a
été raccordé au réseau
il s'est passé pas loin de 30 ans s'est
passé pas loin de 30 ans et on était de
l'avant aiguillonné par un choc
pétrolier qui était encore plus vive
encore plus violent que celui qu'on est
en train de connaître actuellement
voilà donc question est-ce que ça va
être dans les temps pas sûr
pas sûr alors là des gens qui pensent
que oui voilà un scénario dans lequel on
met en service
d'abord des rêves puis des ep air puis
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de
réacteurs en sel fondu mais pour en
arriver là il faut vraiment mettre les
bouchées double il faut vraiment aller
très vite j'ai fini sur la fusion la
fusion est une autre forme d'énergie
nucléaire et je vais finir dessus en
allant très vite parce que nous sommes
encore plus loin de la vérité que en ce
qui concerne la fission la fusion a pour
objet de forcer des petits noyaux qui
ont une force de répulsion
électrostatique forte à se rapprocher
suffisamment pour se rendre compte que
finalement ils sont faits l'un pour
l'autre et à ce colis l'un à l'autre
grâce à l'interaction nucléaire
pour l'instant tout ça reste torride on
excite à plasma
c'est à dire que ont créé à l'intérieur
d'un confinement magnétique que vous
voyez représenter la enfin que vous au
kaki qui se passe dans la bobine
du duo et ça c'est hors supra dans un
confinement magnétique on porte un
plasma à très haute température en
injectant donc de l'énergie dont il ya
d'énergie de chauffage
et quand le placement en question qui
est un placement à d'autres la quatrième
semaine à être portés à une température
suffisante et bien la vitesse des noyaux
est suffisamment importante pour vaincre
la répulsion électrostatique forcer les
noyaux à se rapprocher suffisamment prêt
dans l'autre et à ce moment il fusionne
en libérant une grande quantité
d'énergie sous forme d'un neutron et
d'une particules alpha qui va est
vraiment ça c'est principe général alors
maintenant où est-ce qu'on en ait eu
qu'est ce que ça a comme avantage et
comme inconvénient sur le papier si on
se limite aux dessins sur le papier ça a
des avantages certains
le premier avantage c'est que la
quantité de plasma qui est contenu dans
le temps que je viens de vous montrer
juste avant ses quelques kilos
vous êtes donc vous n'avez pas l'
accident de criticité possible d'accord
le truc qui va nous péter à la figure
c'est pas possible le deuxième avantage
c'est que dès que vous avez une panne
dans votre machine
le confinement du plasma s'arrête et la
réaction s'arrête d'accord donc vous
avez une sécurité passive absolument
merveilleuse qui est que le truc de
papeete et tout ce qui peut se passer si
jamais vous avez un accident dans la
machine ça ne sort quasiment pas du
hangar dans laquelle la chine se trouve
le docteur l'homme est en quantité
quasiment inépuisable puisqu'il
constitue une fraction 2 % de l'eau de
mer donc on va voir d'autres choses
avant 38 deutérium les productions
puisque quand on casse les noyaux
d'uranium en deux vous avez vu qu'on
faisait deux noyaux qui ensuite nous
empoisonner la vie c'était de dire parce
qu'il était très radioactifs et que on
avait du fort voilà que c'était
désagréable de les gérer ou ducasse a
demandé une attention là vous avez une
particule al farjan de trompe il n'y a
pas de produits radioactifs là dedans
cela étant cela étant comme je disais
tout à l'heure on est encore plus loin
d'un réacteur industriel qu'en ce qui
concerne la fission là on n'est pas à 20
ou 30 ans on est à moins 50 ans d'un
résultat industriellement exploitables
donc on
a passé le pic le troll le pégase de
pete charbon et une bonne partie du
changement climatique que iter n'aura
toujours pas débouché sur un dessin
industriel man exploitables d'accord
donc compter là dessus pour sauver vos
petits enfants à mon avis on n'y est pas
encore il ya deux pas à franchir dans la
fusion
la première est de vérifier avec iter
qu'on est capable d'avoir dans un plasma
une réaction de fusion qui produit plus
d'énergie que l'énergie qu'on a injecté
pour chauffer le plasma et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut qu'on vérifie qu
on soit capable de maintenir ce plasma
en température pendant des jours et des
jours parce que pour le moment d'enfer
supra on est capable de faire de minutes
mais avec 2 minutes vous faites par les
acteurs industriels parce que vous allez
pas avoir deux minutes d'électricité
pour votre frigo et puis après ça
s'arrête donc il faut avoir une réaction
qui s'entretiennent beaucoup plus
longtemps
y'aura pas alors un truc intéressant à
savoir c'est que pour le moment c'est
pas la fusion de périodes de terium sur
laquelle les physiciens sont pourtant de
travailler mais la réaction deutérium
tritium le tritium est obtenu à partir
du lit tienne c'est à dire un truc qui
se trouve en sol à des concerts avec de
quantité dans la croûte terrestre qui
sont pas considérablement plus abondante
que lui rend gamin on retienne comme je
le disais sur des pattes tant qu'ils
sont très significatifs à construire
plus expérimentés et puis construire
puis expérimentés et c'est donc celle en
50 ans et enfin
mais encore une fois ce n'est
probablement pas le truc majeur dans
cette affaire pour le moment il n'y a
pas de déchets comme disait inventis
nucléaire de mes amis essentiellement
parce que ça n'existe pas et ils
appâtent heures
il est évident que si ce truc là existe
un jour il y aura des déchets ne serait
ce que parce que le flux de neutrons
qu'on va engendrer sera tellement
important que ça va activer des tas de
trucs ça va sur les nôtres on sert
bouffer par des tas de trucs dans
l'anglais ben du réacteur et ça va à un
moment ou un autre
faire des choses dont il faudra
s'occuper et enfin je vais conclure
secours par une question beaucoup plus
philosophique qui est admettons qu'on
ait accès à une énergie infinie
est ce qu'on est sûr que c'est la fin
des ennuis j'en suis pas sûr je vous
rappelle que l'énergie un fini puisque
l'énergie et l'aptitude à modifier son
environnement c'est une attitude sans
limite à modifier son environnement
ça peut amener aussi un certain nombre
de problèmes voilà un joli